Lesvos a holiday island now synonymous
with migration refugees have been coming
here for five years but now a surge in
both arrivals and tension these migrants
many originally from Afghanistan were
trying to get to the port to seek
passage away from this island and into
mainland Europe they were met by riot
police so for the past twenty minutes or
so the riot police here in lesbos have
been slowly marching away from the port
and pushing the crowds of migrants in
front of them we're now probably the
best not half a kilometre from the port
and they are still advancing trying to
disperse what is hundreds of migrants
who'd gathered here in the center of the
town aid workers and journalists have
been attacked in recent days tempers are
frayed
this is an island with about 80,000
permanent residents now playing home to
perhaps 30 thousand migrants it's a
burden that has wearied people here yes
it will get worse if the government does
not respond to the need for these people
to be transferred to mainland and well
first of all Europe where is Europe what
is Europe doing for five years migrants
have arrived in lesbos here at Maria
Camp built to house 2,000 people now
home to at least 10 times that many
it is squalid and arguably the world's
worst refugee camp hated by just about
everyone what is it like for you to live
because we didn't anything we didn't
respect we are human we leave our
country we lost I lost my job my car my
friend my friends I live here in a tent
without any accommodation you're human
here people doesn't have anything to do
like they cannot work they cannot do
anything they cannot go anywhere you're
like we are in a big prison as Island we
cannot go to other cities we cannot have
a job we cannot I don't know people are
getting more problems in their head the
waters around lesbos are patrolled by
boats from across Europe including this
the valiant from Britain's border force
it alone has rescued around a hundred
and fifty people this week the tide of
migrants is not slowing Adam Parsons Sky
News lesbos